Athènes, mai 2014.
La campagne électorale bat son plein.
Dans les rues, les militants d'Aube Dorée
sont plus que jamais mobilisés.
- Tous les tracts doivent
être distribués, tous !
Les tracts doivent partir,
mais personne ne doit s'éloigner.
Aux élections européennes,
régionales et municipales,
le parti néonazi grec présente
un peu partout des candidats.
- Je suis candidate au conseil régional.
Vous pouvez voter pour moi si vous voulez.
Merci. Bonne journée.
Malgré l'évidence des symboles,
Aube Dorée refuse l'étiquette néonazie,
et se dit simplement nationaliste.
Une chose est sûre,
avec ses bureaux flambant neufs
au cœur d'Athènes,
Aube Dorée est désormais durablement installée
dans le paysage politique du pays.
Le phénomène Aube dorée, c'est le produit
d'un dysfonctionnement majeur,
de l'État grec depuis 2010,
doublé d'une crise économique
sans précédent.
Aujourd'hui, après sept ans de récession,
les Grecs sont à genoux.
Le taux de chômage dépasse les 26%.
Ils ont le sentiment d'être abandonnés
à eux-mêmes.
Face à eux, un État en faillite
et sans réponse concrète.
Depuis 2008, 20 000 manifestations,
souvent violentes,
ont été recensées dans tout le pays.
De nombreuses banques et bâtiments
officiels incendiés et des victimes.
Cinq morts parmi les manifestants
et des dizaines de blessés.
Du pain béni pour Aube Dorée.
Dans ce contexte chaotique,
le parti néonazi,
a multiplié l'ouverture de bureaux
dans tout le pays.
Depuis son entrée
au Parlement en juin 2012,
rien ni personne ne semble pouvoir
arrêter l'ascension du parti néonazi,
qui a fait de la violence
une arme politique.
- Ça suffit maintenant !
Tu ne parles plus !
Lui, il ne parle plus !
- Mais qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
- Casse-toi, sale ordure !
- Je suis nationaliste moi aussi.
- Toi, nationaliste ? Mais casse-toi,
sale p***, ordure !
- Mais pourquoi tu m'insultes ?
Aube dorée profite alors de la complaisance
du gouvernement et de la police,
pour multiplier les attaques envers
les syndicalistes et les immigrés.
Le 17 janvier 2013,
un jeune Pakistanais de 27 ans,
Schehzad Luqman, est poignardé
par deux hommes en noirs,
la police retrouvera
chez eux des tracts d'Aube Dorée.
La résistance prend de l'ampleur.
Mais 8 mois plus tard, Pavlos Fyssas,
rappeur antifasciste,
est lui aussi tué en pleine rue
par un cadre d'Aube dorée,
Yorgos Roupakias.
C'est le meurtre de trop.
D'un seul coup, les Grecs
et les pouvoirs publics,
semblent découvrir un nazi.
Dix jours après la mort
du rappeur Pavlos Fyssas,
le fondateur d'Aube Dorée et 6 députés
sont inculpés pour appartenance,
à une organisation criminelle.
- J'emmerde votre démocratie !
D'autres arrestations suivront.
Contre toute attente, trois députés
sont relâchés dont les plus virulents,
Ilias Panagiotaros
et Ilias Kasidiaris,
33 ans, agronome de formation
et étoile montante du parti.
Officiellement, Aube Dorée condamne
le meurtre de Pavlos Fyssas,
ses députés nient même
connaître son assassin.
- On a appris qui était ce Mr Roupakias
et ce qu'il a fait.
Mais après l'assassinat.
Je ne le connaissais pas.
Aucun de nous ne le connaissait.
C'était juste un sympathisant
parmi tant d'autres.
Ça et rien de plus.
Pourtant, lors de nos 2 années de tournage,
nous l'avons souvent croisé.
Ici aux côtés du député Panagiotaros,
lors d'une distribution de nourriture,
en juillet 2013.
Là, trois mois plus tard,
toujours en uniforme,
à une manifestation du parti.
Des preuves inédites
à ce jour que Roupakias,
était bien un membre actif d'Aube Dorée
et non un simple sympathisant.
C'est alors qu'un groupe
t**** d'extrême gauche,
inconnu jusque là, venge le meurtre
du rappeur Pavlos Fyssas.
Deux militants d'Aube Dorée sont abattus de
sang froid aux pieds de leur quartier général.
Le parti tient ses martyrs.
Aube dorée, désormais, joue aux victimes,
mais continue
ses démonstrations de force,
comme dans cette cérémonie de Nuremberg
version locale à l'automne dernier.
À la tribune, Ilias Kasidiaris
lance sa campagne électorale.
- L'objectif d'Aube Dorée est de placer des
élus dans toutes les grandes villes du pays.
Pas seulement Athènes,
Thessalonique ou le Pirée.
On veut gérer le pays avec des mains
propres, qu'on écrase la corruption,
et qu'il y ait à nouveau une purification
politique et que la loi règne.
Nos priorités seront les suivantes :.
1 : la corruption et le gaspillage
d'argent public.
2 : la criminalité.
3 : le commerce illégal.
Ce sont là les trois grandes questions
qui préoccupent les Grecs.
Et quand je parle de criminalité
et de commerce illégal,
je parle évidemment,
exclusivement des étrangers.
Ça ne concerne pas les Grecs.
Des Grecs tentés de voter Aube dorée,
le centre d'Athènes en compte beaucoup.
Tous ces damnés de la crise
pour qui le moindre sou est compté,
comme Stella.
- Vous en voulez plus ?
- Non, ça me suffit.
Ça coûte combien ?
- 1€.
Stella, veuve de 65 ans,
vit proche du seuil de pauvreté.
Un seuil qui concerne désormais
un tiers des Grecs.
- 1€.
- Je viens ici parce que c'est moins cher
et je peux m'en sortir,
ailleurs, je n'y arrive pas.
Au marché, notre présence déclenche
très vite des commentaires.
- Vous le dites sur vos chaînes
que les gens ont faim ?
Les gens ont faim et le gouvernement
ne s'en est même pas encore rendu compte.
Qu'ils aillent tous se faire f**** !
- Non, ne dites pas ça.
Ces mots sont interdits.
- Pourquoi ne pas le dire ?
Pourquoi ?
Regardez comment ils ont laissé les gens.
- Non, tout va bien.
Tout le monde va bien.
- Venez me demander à moi aussi
ce que je vais voter.
Je vais vous dire la vérité.
Moi, je vais voter
pour la gauche radicale,
pour changer les données
de madame Merkel.
C'est ça que je vais voter !
On doit réagir !
Gauche radicale ou Aube dorée,
dans le marché aux poissons,
le choix est clair,
ici, les drapeaux grecs sont nombreux.
Un symbole depuis quelques années
confisquées par le parti néonazi.
- Aube Dorée est
de plus en plus puissante.
Elle a tout ce qu'il lui faut
pour prospérer, la misère,
la faim, le malheur, le chômage.
Tout y est !
- Avec ce morceau de fromage,
on va pouvoir tenir un bon moment.
Une fois les courses rangées,
Stella fait ses comptes.
Elle touche une retraite de 655€.
Avec cette somme, elle doit vivre
et faire vivre aussi son fils,
son neveu et sa petite fille.
Dans une telle situation, aller chercher
de l'aide auprès d'Aube Dorée,
est la solution la plus simple
qu'elle ait trouvée.
- J'ai été deux fois
à leur distribution de nourriture.
Ils m'ont donné
des pommes de terre, des tomates,
du raisin, des poissons.
Si Aube Dorée organise encore une distribution
de nourriture, j'irai, c'est sûr.
J'ai été demander de l'aide à la mairie,
mais ils demandent un tas de justificatifs.
Pas chez Aube Dorée.
Ils sont des milliers comme Stella
à faire la queue partout,
où Aube Dorée organise
des distributions de nourriture.
Exclusivement réservé aux Grecs,
chrétiens et blancs,
les bénéficiaires doivent impérativement
montrer leur carte d'identité.
Des heures d'attente pour ramener chez soi
de quoi tenir ne serait ce que quelques jours.
- Je suis venue car j'ai de gros problèmes
financiers. Je dois manger quand même !
Mes enfants sont au chômage,
mon mari est malade,
et je veux que justice soit rendue
contre ces voleurs du gouvernement.
- Vous pensez qu'Aube dorée
peut le faire ?
- Oui, même si je suis en désaccord
avec leurs procédés,
ils le peuvent et je veux vraiment que ceux
qui ont vidé les caisses de l'Etat soient jugés.
Pour Aube Dorée, ces distributions
très fréquentes font partie intégrante,
de sa stratégie de campagne.
- Combattant, s'il te plaît,
viens ici un instant.
- J'arrive tout de suite.
Lors de ses dons de nourriture, les députés
d'Aube Dorée, comme Ilias Kasidiaris,
sont toujours présents et bien visibles.
- Ça va suffire ?
- Ça va être juste.
On a amené 5 camions,
mais on ne pensait pas
qu'il y aurait autant de monde.
De nombreux bénéficiaires
et autant d'électeurs potentiels.
Cet hiver devant le Parlement,
plus de 10 000 militants,
se sont réunis à l'appel du parti.
À l'ordre du jour, la libération
immédiate du fondateur d'Aube dorée,
ainsi que de deux de ses députés.
- Aube Dorée n'est pas entrée
au Parlement avec les chars,
comme leurs médias corrompus le racontent.
Mais avec votre vote et un slogan
"Les voleurs en prison".
C'est ça l'exigence du moment !
Comme d'habitude, Kasisiaris galvanise
ses troupes sans aucune note.
Nous, nous sommes l'avenir
et eux, le passé !
De quoi convaincre les derniers indécis.
Rahis n'est pas de ceux là.
Militants d'Aube Dorée de longue date,
cet ancien pilote d'hélicoptère de l'armée
s'est investi de plus en plus,
au fil des années.
- Père de 2 enfants,
Rahis possède aujourd'hui un petit
restaurant devenu le point de ralliement,
de ses amis militants.
- Et voilà les souvlaki !
- Tout ce qu'on dit sur vous, les Sections
d'Assaut, les agressions racistes.
C'est vrai ?
- Non, ça n'existe pas.
On est simplement nationalistes
et rien d'autre.
On aime simplement notre pays.
- Ce qui m'a fait entrer de façon
active dans Aube Dorée,
c'était tous les problèmes
avec cette crise.
Et la solution qui doit être donnée
doit être nationaliste,
c'est-à-dire...
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut
y arriver tout seul.
On a besoin de personne,
on est un peuple,
une civilisation, un pays qui a tout.
On n'a besoin de personne,
ni de l'Allemagne,
ni des Américains, ni des Juifs.
- Ce qu'a réussi Aube Dorée,
personne d'autre ne l'a réussi.
Ni les socialistes, ni les communistes.
C'est l'entraide
des uns envers les autres.
On vient de toutes
les couches de la société.
Nous sommes des forces hétéroclites.
Du plus bas au plus
haut niveau de la société.
Mais on est regroupé, solidaires
et on s'entraide de façon désintéressée.
Parce que le danger en ce moment
est à nos portes.
Le lendemain,
Rahis nous accueille chez lui.
Ici, tout le monde soutient son engagement
dans Aube Dorée, surtout sa femme Ioulia.
- Quand nous nous sommes connus,
nous avions les mêmes convictions.
Cela continue et ce que nous décidons,
nous le décidons toujours en commun.
N'est-ce pas belle maman ?
Dans cette famille de militaires
depuis des générations,
on a commencé à voter Aube Dorée
bien avant la faillite du pays.
- Ce n'est pas que la crise économique,
c'est également les questions nationales.
Mon autre fils aussi est militaire,
comme mon mari.
Je ne peux plus accepter la réduction
des budgets de la défense,
ni les humiliations que subit
régulièrement notre patrie.
Je n'en peux plus !
Comme la plupart des cadres d'Aube dorée,
Rahis est passionné d'histoire.
Dans sa bibliothèque, de nombreux ouvrages
sur la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
sa passion.
- Le nationaliste grec lit,
nous lisons pour apprendre.
C'est ce qui nous rend
supérieur aux autres.
Et pour Rahis, tous les auteurs se valent.
- Mein Kampf, je l'ai aussi en grec.
Ça c'est une copie, mais je l'ai
aussi en version originale,
achetée à Londres dans une galerie.
Là, c'est l'original. Regardez, 1938.
À l'époque il y a eu
4 millions d'exemplaires imprimés.
Mais ça ne veut rien dire
que j'ai le Mein Kampf de Hitler.
Je l'ai lu, c'est tout !
Deux exemplaires de Mein Kampf chez lui,
malgré tout, Rahis refuse l'étiquette
de raciste ou de nazi.
- Tous ceux qui désormais quittent
leur pays pour venir en Grèce,
Pourquoi je me les coltine moi ?
Pourquoi pas la France ?
Pourquoi j'accueillerai tous ces milliers
de clandestins qui viennent du Pakistan ?
Des musulmans qui essayent
de m'imposer leur religion,
demandent des droits
et je ne sais quoi d'autre,
et viennent faire leur d**** en Grèce.
Rahis assume ce discours anti-immigré,
sa caution,
ses actions humanitaires passées.
- Moi, Quand j'étais en Afrique,
j'ai aidé tant que j'ai pu.
Mais pour qu'il reste chez lui, le noir.
Pas qu'ils viennent chez moi altérer ma race.
Il n'y a pas de noirs dans la race grecque.
Et pour préserver la race grecque,
Aube Dorée va jusqu'au bout de sa logique.
Elle organise des collectes
de sang grecs pour les Grecs.
- Il faut prendre
tous les gens qui attendent,
et ceux qui sont jusque là
passent en priorité.
Selon la loi, sauf urgence, l'hôpital doit
réserver ce sang pour les patients grecs.
- On essaye de faire tout ce que l'on peut
pour aider le plus de gens possible.
Une mise en scène de plus pour Aube Dorée
en cette période de campagne électorale.
- Aujourd'hui, c'est la journée
de collecte de sang national pour Aube Dorée.
C'est encore une action sociale
de notre parti.
Comme vous voyez, il y a des centaines
de gens, des concitoyens,
qui offrent un peu de leur sang.
Ces actions vont continuer malgré
les réactions inadmissibles que cela suscite.
Les actions chocs, provocatrices,
c'est la tactique d'Aube dorée.
Et c'est sur la toile que le parti
poursuit son travail de propagande.
Depuis le quartier général
du parti, Ilias Kasidiaris,
parle aux militants une fois
par semaine via Internet,
avec des messages comme sur ce tract
toujours teinté de provocation.
- J'ai aimé cette photo dès le premier
jour à ma sortie du tribunal.
Je me suis alors dit que le meilleur message
pour ces élections passerait par cette image.
Elle est vraie, ce n'est pas un montage.
Nous avons subi une véritable persécution,
mais nous y faisons face avec le sourire.
On nous traite de nazis, de fascistes,
mais on nous a aussi traités
de t**** et de gauchistes.
parce que nous,
on n'a jamais commis de crimes,
on n'a jamais volé de l'argent public.
Comme ils n'ont rien à dire sur nous,
ils ont inventé toute cette histoire
de nazisme et même de satanisme.
On a entendu tout un tas de bêtises sur
nous car ils n'ont rien à nous reprocher.
Nous, on a les mains propres.
Pourtant, la police a fourni récemment
à la presse de nombreuses photos,
qui prouvent le contraire.
Nous retrouvons Rahis.
Deux fois par semaine, l'ancien pilote se rend
dans les bureaux d'Aube Dorée de son quartier.
Pour la première fois, il autorise
des journalistes à pénétrer dans ces locaux.
- Bonsoir tout le monde !
Tout va bien ?
À l'entrée, les gros bras
montent la garde.
- Bonsoir.
- Tiens, il y a les caméras avec toi.
À l'étage, les sympathisants
sont déjà nombreux.
Rahis, lui, est chargé de motiver les
troupes, de recruter de nouveaux membres,
et de collecter des fonds.
- Là, ce sont les coupons
qui permettent de soutenir le parti,
grâce aux dons des militants.
Ici, on entretient le culte
du passé glorieux du pays,
dont Aube Dorée se réclame sans cesse.
En novembre dernier, le local a été
attaqué et saccagé par des opposants.
Depuis, Rahis a renforcé la sécurité.
- Ici, nous avons des portes blindées.
Et à l'entrée des bureaux,
une grille supplémentaire,
un système d'alarme, des caméras
extérieures et intérieures.
On est en guerre. Une guerre permanente
et de longue durée.
- Est-ce qu'on peut organiser
la salle un peu ?
Ce soir, les sympathisants sont réunis pour
une lecture commentée du journal du parti.
Au programme, un fait divers sordide,
une jeune fille agressée
et v**** par un migrant.
- Si on réagit, on est des racistes.
Le sommes nous ?
Je ne sais pas. Je vous le demande.
Sommes nous des racistes ?
Nous, on est nationaliste.
Nationaliste ! On n'est pas fascistes.
On n'est pas nazis.
Ce que nous voulons, c'est la libération de
notre patrie. Et qu'il nous foute la paix !
La réunion se termine.
Rahis, lui, a oublié qu'il portait un micro
et donne des consignes à Constantina,
La militante qui doit
nous parler le lendemain.
Le lendemain, nous retrouvons
Constantina en campagne.
Elle nous répète
alors fidèlement sa leçon.
Ce ne sont pas les Grecs
qui ont fait la Shoah.
On n'a aucun rapport avec cela. Si cela
a eu lieu, nous, on n'est pas responsable.
Si cela a eu lieu.
Constantina vient d'un milieu très aisé.
Assistante juridique, elle a perdu
son emploi l'année dernière.
Désormais, elle est candidate
aux élections régionales pour Aube Dorée.
Je vous donne un tract.
Vous voulez bien ?
Bonne journée.
- Vous savez ce que c'est ?
- Oui, je sais.
Vous êtes d'accord, les chefs d'Aube dorée
sont des prisonniers politiques ?
- Chacun ses opinions.
- C'est-à-dire ?
- J'y crois et je n'y crois pas.
- C'est à dire ?
- C'est bon...
Les gens ont peur, le fait qu'ils aient pris
le tract devant la caméra sans le refuser,
ça veut dire beaucoup, ça veut dire
je suis d'accord avec vous,
sinon, il nous l'aurait
lancé à la figure.
Le lendemain, Constantina
nous invite chez elle.
- Bonjour !
Pour nous parler de son engagement.
Constantina a demandé à des amis de venir,
elles aussi militantes convaincues.
- Anna, tu fais du Thé ?
Ce qui m'a fait forte impression
en allant voir Aube Dorée,
c'est qu'il parlait de la Grèce...
de la Grèce et des Grecs.
Et puis à la fin, ils ont dit :
"Levez-vous qu'on chante
l'hymne national."
Je me suis dit : "Où suis-je ?"
Je vous dis, moi, je n'y croyais pas.
J'avais la chair de poule.
Je pleurais vraiment.
Je pleurais quand j'ai entendu l'hymne
national. J'ai dit C'est fini.
Je voterai désormais pour Aube Dorée.
La Grèce aux Grecs chrétiens.
La Grèce appartient aux Grecs.
Tu es née Grec,
tu ne peux pas le devenir.
- Moi, avant, je votais
pour le Parti socialiste,
jusqu'en avril début mai 2012, quand
je suis allé m'inscrire à Aube Dorée.
Peu avant les premières élections,
avec tout ce qu'on avait entendu,
les rumeurs,
les accusations de terrorisme...
Au début, je me suis dit
"c'est qui ces gens ?",
J'ai quand même demandé leur programme.
Et il me convenait à 100%.
En fait, c'était des gens super sympas,
des jeunes très bien élevés.
Des militants sympathiques, serviables,
à l'image de Rahis.
Désormais candidat à la mairie d'un quartier
huppé de la banlieue d'Athènes.
- Il faut la mettre plus haut en sécurité,
pour que les autres ne l'arrachent pas.
Jusqu'ici, Aube dorée faisait le plein des
voix dans les quartiers les plus défavorisés.
Aujourd'hui, elle vise aussi
les classes supérieures.
Dans ce blog, c'est pour vous mener.
- Ici, aux dernières élections,
Aube Dorée a obtenu 6,9% des voix.
Maintenant, on est à plus dix.
Ce sont des gens
de toutes les classes sociales,
mais essentiellement des moyens et hauts revenus,
eux aussi touchés par la crise.
Rahis a revêtu sa plus belle chemise
pour son premier meeting.
Désormais, Aube dorée lisse
son image et son discours.
Il ne faut plus effrayer mais séduire
les citoyens bien sous tout rapport.
Je veux des Grecs qui pensent !
Des Grecs qui peuvent créer.
Je veux l'esprit d'Ulysse !
Et l'audace d'Achille !
Les élections montreront si les Grecs
se sont laissés séduire par cette stratégie.
Une certitude, si militants et cadres d'Aube
dorée se veulent plus fréquentables aujourd'hui,
leur hymne, lui, ne laisse guère
de doute sur leurs intentions.